bonsoir à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans le journal de tv 78 voici les
titres de ce mercredi 2 juin le
déconfinement se poursuit d'ici une
semaine à partir du 9 juin
nous entrerons dans la 3e phase prévue
par le gouvernement
parmi les nouvelles mesures le
télétravail ne sera plus obligatoire
mais seulement recommandée en entreprise
comment cela va-t-il se passer dans les
yvelines
rencontre avec le directeur des
ressources humaines de thales vélizy et
notre invité à ce sujet philippe cornier
directeur du réseau entreprendre
yvelines direction bucs ensuite où un
spectacle contre les violences faites
aux femmes étaient organisées le
week-end dernier sur scène comédienne
assistante sociale et femmes victimes de
violences objectif redonner confiance et
sensibiliser et en fin d'émission focus
sur l'édition 2021 du festival et all
factory c'est l'un des seuls festivals à
avoir pu se maintenir l'an passé et il
sera de retour en septembre prochain
avec toujours le même but mettre en
avant les instruments à vent
comme je vous le disais en titre la
troisième étape du déconfinement aura
lieu le 9 juin prochain
pour les entreprises cette étape
marquera la fin de l'obligation du
télétravail à 100 % pour ceux qui le
pouvaient sur le site de thalès à vélizy
même si le télétravail ne va pas être
totalement abandonné le retour des
salariés se précise
interview du directeur des ressources
humaines au micro de bérangère bourgoin
[Musique]
et bien au niveau du groupe il avait
signé un accord pour refonder les thales
et donc on va on va travailler avec les
équipes pour définir les meilleurs modes
d'organisation entre le présentiel et le
travail sa chambre et l'on estime donc
le tetra et bois doit pas y céder à deux
jours par semaine
[Musique]
sur le site dont on va déjà voir s'il
est nécessaire de maintenir un certain
nombre de principes des mesures
barrières et pour du coup dans ce cas là
on à date on adapte la configuration des
services des aménagements qui sera
proposé et donc le thé trahi par exemple
à la bascule en titraille potentiel sera
sera gérée à l'aune de ses assurés je
pense que le 2 juin va pas être là bas
un petit peu de temps pour avec les
équipes et s'organiser donc on utilisera
la situation stabilisée pour continuer à
parler de cette troisième étape du
déconfinement et de cette fin
d'obligations de télétravail est à 100%
nous accueillons philippe cormier
bonsoir vous êtes le directeur du réseau
entreprendre yvelines alors je le
rappelle le 9 juin
c'est donc la fin de cette obligation de
télétravail est à 100% cela avait été
mise en place depuis octobre 2020 pour
dans le cadre évidemment de cette crise
sanitaire
depuis janvier les salariés pouvait déjà
revenir une journée par semaine en
présentiel le 9 juin donc ce sera
possible
toute la semaine mais certaines
entreprises on l'a entendu comme thales
vélizy ont fait le choix de conserver et
d'être de rester même prudent sur cette
date du 9 juin
philippe cormier vous êtes donc au
contact des chefs d'entreprise via votre
réseau entreprendre yvelines
un réseau qui représentent
essentiellement des tpe des pme mais
aussi des deux pays
comment ces petites ou moyennes
entreprises après intel c'est troisième
étape du déconfinement potentiellement
javier d'un gué
et des plus grosses structures et je
pense qu'il faut adapter la dictée
rencontre les secteurs d'activité on
peut voir d'autres que depuis quelques
mois
pendant la période de confinement les
entretenir un petit con des interactions
comme et d'artisans vêtements ou de
maintenance gérait de demain de tas de
matériaux ne comparez pas manquer tout
ne peut pas faire du continent dont le
télétravail en fait dire la part où
aller ils ont été travaillées n'a pas
changé grand chose pour eux par contre
les activités de tallinn ou tertiaire
les pompiers ont déjà préparé en fait
annick biren pompe travaillant présente
elle est un travail
par contre pour certaines ça va nous
demander de revoir dirait l'homme
méthodes de travail actuellement dédiés
aux dirigeants de passer à côté d'eux
tran j'irai sur la communication avec
les équipes ne va pas amener et raturer
en termes de mesures sanitaires en
termes de prix de travail
je crois que ça va demander énormément
on veut pas et nous y reviendrons
justement dans un instant philippe
cormier ce que vous évoquez justement
sur cette préparation de l'organisation
du retour en entreprise juste avant cela
je vous me parliez du maintien du
télétravail en partie entre guillemets
et puis d'un retour pour certains
secteurs
j'imagine que vous parlez du secteur
tertiaire notamment en perthois déjà
chez les salariés de continuer le
travail entre tous les fils en fait pour
4 mains pour créer de refuser des
demandes
sachant que pour la plupart des
entreprises l'activité irait à continuer
même avec un grand majorité des salariés
en télétravail vont peut être regretter
le travailleur peut marcher un peu court
pour certaines entreprises dans est
étendue au pouvoir en fait être à
l'écouté des salariés des collaborateurs
appellent pour savoir comment il faut
être organisé
peu bavard il est avec moi pour les
gants et pourquoi cette tendance selon
vous alors dans secteur tertiaire on
comprend dans le bâtiment chez les
commerçants c'est un peu plus compliqué
en effet de télétravail et vous l'avez
dit pourquoi cette tendance chez les
salariés chez les chefs d'entreprise de
maintenir cette forme finalement de
travail de gérer la crise à laquelle
nous convie nous a démontré que lequel
travaille en fait championnat puis des
salariés peuvent avoir un environnement
pour avril de m
la deuxième chose et chaque partie peut
la période de réadaptation un peu temps
clément certaines me perds tu aimes la
vie est un peu de rythme en parfaite de
retourner en fait au travail de de
prendre autrement d'eric norme étant en
contact avec d'autres d'autres personnes
je pars tu vas voir
moi je crois qu'il y avoir au moins deux
ou trois mois et aux entreprises et à
leurs collaborateurs en peu de pour se
réadapter en fait à ces notions de
dominique de télétravail et nos
pensionnaires
alors du coup pour certaines entreprises
aussi d'avoir mis en place pour ces
salariés se télétravail à 100% ça aussi
était un investissement tant sur le plan
financier que logistique ça a parfois
été compliqué on imagine bien pour
certaines tpe ou pme notamment sur le
numérique pour vous est-ce que cela
influe aussi sur les salariés sur les
chefs d'entreprise de vouloir maintenir
ce côté télétravail et d'erevan
il a été fait en sorte que comme thème
avec des porcs avec avec a pas paru trop
tranquille pour il faut garder
techniquement
mais je manque et elle est plutôt en
fait entrer parce que quand on trouve le
bon équilibre entre le télétravail et le
présentiel
l'entreprise peut être très
opérationnelle même voire plus
performante que précédemment et le
télétravail comme à porter pour certains
des collaborateurs est l allié à une
amélioration de la qualité de vie pour
ceux qui pouvaient le faire concrètement
donc il ya haute ils demandent notamment
tête de cobra coeur de garder
j'aurais peut-être qu'a été le big de
pouvoir travailler différente ne pas
avoir à prendre les transports en commun
ou prends ta voiture est passée trois
quarts d'heure voire plus d'une heure en
fait dans les trois prochains beaucoup
d'eux de fatigue et de stress et je
pense que il va y avoir retiré de
l'équateur a trouvé en fait fausse route
et travailler de l'ancien bon je pense
que ses pétales que pour le bien de
l'entreprise
deux entrepreneurs et de but à la merci
philippe cormier je rappelle que vous
êtes le directeur du réseau entreprendre
yvelines merci encore pour toutes ces
précisions
dans le reste de l'actualité dans les
yvelines une pièce de théâtre pour
sensibiliser aux violences conjugales
c'est ce qui a eu lieu à buc dimanche 30
mai au théâtre des arcades la pièce
quand les mots guérissent les mots c'est
son nom fait suite au constat du réseau
violences conjugales du grand versailles
de la nécessité pour ces femmes de
parler en dehors d'un suivi
psychologique individuel sur scène
comédienne assistante sociale et femmes
victimes de violences
objectif redonner confiance et
sensibiliser le reportage de justin
brasier face à ce constat la ville de
buc en partenariat avec le territoire
départemental du grand versailles a mis
en place un atelier qui s'inscrit dans
leur accompagnement
le but créer une pièce de théâtre quand
les mots guérissent les mots objectif
leur donner confiance des femmes qui se
sont révélés pour reprise justement la
confiance et l'estimé d'elles-mêmes
l'une d'ailleurs n'était pas sur scène
pascal a retrouvé du travail une autre
qui a retrouvé la force da de pouvoir
voyager de retrouver des amis sa famille
chose qu'elle ne n'avais plus la force
de faire qu'elle n'osait plus faire donc
des nouvelles femmes et on voit que leur
témoignage et l'auditoire qu'on leur a
donné aujourd'hui participe aussi à la
reconstruction long cours la
représentation a pris place au théâtre
des arcades de but qu elles ont écrit et
joué leurs propres textes avec l'aide de
comédienne et d'un metteur en scène
chacune a amené quelque chose de
personnel sous forme de danse théâtre ou
encore témoignages on a bien compris en
discutant après avec elle que en fait ça
leur avait servi aussi à passer en fait
une ce moment
à mettre des mots sur leurs douleurs
leurs difficultés qu'a pu connaître dans
le sang sur scène quatre femmes
objectif pour elle tourner la page mais
aussi témoigner pour toutes celles et
qui subissent des violences
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
je pensais à toutes ces femmes qui on
avait pas eu la chance de pouvoir s'en
sortir de trouver la bonne personne qui
les aurait aidés qui auraient toutes ces
femmes qui avaient pas au fur et à
mesure des mois et des années sans thil
à la force qu'on a tout en fait en nous
mais qu'on développe pas suffisamment
parce qu'on sait pas comment faire
et on n'ose pas le faire et je voulais
parler pour elle la ville de buc
envisage de poursuivre ce projet par la
rédaction d'une bande dessinée
le but mettre sur papier ce témoignage
est sensibilisé la ville espère
également tourné ce spectacle dans
d'autres villes désignées leur vie nous
venons donnant de lui mais aussi pour
celles qui ont basculé largement
direction le che mais rocancourt à
présent depuis mi mai la bibliothèque
s'est lancé dans le portage de livres à
domicile les personnes ne pouvant pas se
déplacer peuvent profiter de ce service
gratuit
les précisions de célia guettent son go
à dos bonjour c'est la bibliothèque du
chêne rock encore les appels
s'enchaînent à la bibliothèque du chéné
rocancourt depuis mai les chaînés
courtois qu'ils ne peuvent pas se
déplacer bénéficient gratuitement du
portage de livres à domicile
on appelle ça un portage plus qu'une
livraison parce que le but aussi c'est
de rompre un isolement de la personne
d'avoir un moment d'échangés de
sociabilité avec elle alors dans le
contexte sanitaire actuelle c'est un peu
limité on fait une livraison pas de la
porte
mais l'idée à terme dans un contexte
sanitaire normal c'est qu'on aura en
temps d'échangé avec la personne
ça pourrait être un échange autour de
ses dernières lectures des conseils en
majorité ce sont des personnes âgées qui
ont recours à ce dispositif
mais les personnes handicapées femmes
enceintes ou encore souffrant d'une
pathologie peuvent aussi en profiter
ce matin-là une bibliothécaire cherche
des livres pour une personne âgée qu'il
a appelé un peu plus tôt en fait c'est
très important voyez le coup de fil
parce que ça peut être très bref si la
personne a vraiment des auteurs tels que
des jeux le lien ni musso je veux lévy
etc
là on peut passer très peu de temps
maintenant si c'est quelqu'un qui n'a
pas d'idées
c'est très très important de prendre son
temps vous voyez à l'ennemi tueur ne
compte pas mon temps quand je suis au
téléphone parce que on essaye de trouver
au mieux ce qui correspond à ses goûts
une fois les livres
trouvez emmanuel de lille les met dans
un sac avec une liste de questions pour
affiner les recherches futures pour
l'instant le portage de documents à
domicile se fait une demi journée par
semaine
arrivé chez la bénéficiaire la
bibliothécaire dépôt des livres sur le
pas de la porte
j'apprécie énormément collin porte à
domicile ça c'était agréable d'autant
plus que ma chaise je commence à avoir
un peu de mal à marcher aller aussi loin
et j'ai l'intention d'en parler autour
de moi jusqu'à dix documents peuvent
être livrés toutes les quatre semaines
c'est l'un des seuls festivals à avoir
pu se tenir malgré le coc vie de l'année
dernière le festival et all factory de
mantes-la-jolie sera bien de retour en
septembre prochain un festival avec une
particularité pour le moins original
mettre en avant les instruments à vent
reportage de bixente mais rien senti
stevan le festival elle aura bien lieu
du 10 au 12 septembre prochain sur l'île
l'aumône de mantes la jolie pour la
troisième édition des festivités le
principe reste le même ce festival
présente la particularité d'être
l'occasion de la mise en valeur de la
facture instrumentale des manufactures
d'instruments de musique à vent qui sont
situées sur le territoire et plus
précisément à mantes la ville
on a aujourd'hui deux leaders mondiaux
qui sont dans le mantois qui fabrique
d'instruments musique donc pouvoir
porter un événement culturel de
dimension nationale qu'ils fassent un
clin d'oeil à cette identité c'est
évidemment une satisfaction particulière
ainsi la programmation fait en sorte
qu'un instrument à vent soit sur scène
pour chaque concert et des concerts il y
en aura plus de 20 avec certains visages
connus du grand public
en ce qui concerne les têtes d'affiché
nous avons le vendredi principalement
kassav
nous avons le samedi rhoda scott et les
avec entouré d'un orchestre féminin et
le dimanche debout sur le zinc et thomas
dutronc les jeunes d'en bas c'est cette
année pour tous les artistes demandent
qu'à jouer
c'est relativement facile de les faire
venir ils ont envie de jouer ils
connaissent le lieu et 12,3 pour le
mieux
les incertitudes liées à la coved qui
n'influe pas sur la programmation mais
plutôt sur l'organisation
on part sur un festival qui a une jauge
inférieur à 1000 personnes
et donc voilà on reste dans ce cadre qui
elle qui est établie aujourd'hui on a
anticipé beaucoup de choses donc l'idée
c'est que ça joue on est quand même dans
des métiers qui vont sait s'adapter on
est réactif et on le fera si on doit
s'adapter dans un sens ou dans un autre
en tout cas l'idée c'est que ça joue au
mois de septembre les tarifs pour les
places varie entre 25 et 33 euros pour
un jour des pass 3 jours sont également
en vente à 62 euros d'abord en quantité
limitée puis 78 euros pour refermer ce
journal la bergerie nationale de
rambouillet a organisé samedi 29 mai la
deuxième édition de sa formation à
l'apiculture
le centre d'enseignement aux techniques
a accueilli 12 amateurs et
professionnels qui ont pu apprendre à
gérer un rucher reportage de bérangère
bourgoin et mélanie poké ils étaient les
12 à enfiler leurs combinaisons à
l'occasion de la deuxième journée de
formation à l'apiculture qui a eu lieu à
la bergerie nationale
alors on a à la fois du grand public
complètement
non initiés qui vient ici avant
d'acheter des ruches de se lancer dans
l'apiculture presser pour le stage de
découverte
et puis là aujourd'hui c'est un stage de
perfectionnement donc on a des gens qui
gèrent déjà quelques ruches
on peut avoir aussi des professionnels
l'environnement du paysage qui dans le
cas de leurs activités gère des riches
la formation a commencé avec les
technique d'enfumage des abeilles
le but pour la bergerie à prendre aux
participants à se perfectionner pour
développer ou pérennité sont bouchées on
s'y intéresse mais tout le monde pense
aussi que c'est facile donc mais nous on
est aussi là pour aiguiller les gens les
aider à faire les bons choix se lancer
ou pas tout seul ou accompagné
amateurs ou professionnels les inscrits
à cette formation ont pu compléter leur
première journée découverte du 22 mai au
sein d'un des trois gauchers et des 70
colonies d'abeilles de la bergerie j'ai
en fait dans la maison de famille on a
des ruches depuis très longtemps et la
personne qui s'en occupe
peut plus s'en occuper donc voilà le but
c'est de se former pour pouvoir prendre
la relève sur la gestion du risque et
donc un peu on va dire un cadre l'organe
de ce soit plus clair dans ma tête donc
puis là franchement c'est très bien
c'est hyper secteur la bergerie
nationale organise ces formations deux
fois par an au printemps pour respecter
le rythme des abeilles
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
l'avoir suivi je vous laisse avec ma
collègue mélanie poquet pour le 7-8
société le cetud journal lui revient
demain présenté par grégory canal et à
18h en direct d'ici là retrouvez nous
sur nos réseaux sociaux tv 118 points
comme notre site internet et notre
application mobile tv 78 et je vous
souhaite une très bonne soirée
[Musique]